this is Startalk what does neuroscience
say about empathy because they're people
who are not autistic who don't have
empathy like certain kinds of criminals
who can I was gonna say late we do call
them sociopaths that's gotta be a big
factor in the study oh yeah there's been
great research actually on empathy and
and how hard it is for people with
autism some of this comes out of England
actually from a guy named Simon
baron-cohen
he's a cousin of Sacha Baron Cohen as it
turns out I was gonna guess that how do
you do that but he shows pictures just
of people's eyes and he asked them that
he asked the subjects try to tell me
what emotion this person is showing are
they angry
are they dreamy are they upset are they
happy people with autism have a really
hard time doing that just like Temple is
saying right and it's it's but is it
trainable it's hard to train in it like
like Temple is saying she's we drink
turn out pretty good yeah but I'm still
a sociopath say that's the problem not
that is what sociopaths do they don't
feel the empty empathy but unlike
somebody like Temple they learn the
actual cues that they should be
mimicking bondage has feelings so you
know the angry eyes they recognize as
anger and then they respond in kind but
they don't really feel anything when
they do it yeah got a feeling I'm gonna
get a call from the FBI after this show
other is there a tendency for artistic
people to need to be medicated tempo
headstrong sort of bouts with anxiety
yeah definitely a lot of people with
autism have other medical issues going
on psychiatric things like anxiety
epilepsy also you need medication for
that if I tip my hat to the
psychopharmacologist so whoever is is
that's out there doing this it can help
no question yeah
I'm just sorry that I spent all this
time doing drugs and alcohol instead of
taking antidepressants
but is there the risk of addiction and
people you know the these drugs of
course have side effects like all drugs
we don't want them overused but they
have their place and they can be very
helpful for some people with autism but
you have to that's it he just sounded
like yes we just trial and error because
you said it's trial and error medicines
and empirical science right right right
thinks if they don't work with dress-up
if they work great this is Startalk